- [Mark] All right, Tanya.
Tanya, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from, originally?
- [Tanya] I'm from Los
Angeles, California.
- [Mark] And tell me about your-
- [Tanya] And I grew up
in South Central, L.A.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were young?
- No, my dad raised us,
because he told us that my
mother was a unfit mother
and that she wasn't up to
par to take care of us.
- [Mark] So your mom wasn't in your life?
- No, no.
Partially, partially.
I would have to run away from home
to go see my mom.
and she stayed down here, downtown.
- [Mark] Is that right?
- Yeah.
And my dad, he used-
he used to jump on my
mother a lot, you know.
Because my mother had
turned to liking women,
so, he wouldn't allow her to see us.
- [Mark] And how would you
describe your childhood?
- Rough. Rough.
- [Mark] What kinda stuff went on?
- I got-, I got, a, like
not just a whooping,
I got maybe like a beatin' every day.
You know, my dad,
he took a lot of his anger out on me,
that he had for my mom,
because I looked like her.
I guess that was his way of showing me,
you know, on his suspicion on how he feel.
You know, which,
when I got older, I did ask him,
why did he do me like that?
I got a whooping, I left
home at 12 years old.
You know, I came home one day,
and, my sister was on the porch crying,
and I asked her why, 'cause
he had a lot of women,
you know, different women
every other now and then.
- [Mark] What did your dad do for money?
- He sold dope.
Sold crack cocaine.
And...
it's, it's, it-.
- [Mark] So, a lot of physical abuse?
- Yes, a lot.
- [Mark] Any sexual abuse?
- No, no, no.
Not at all, not at all.
He never did nothin' like that to me,
or one of my sisters,
that I'm aware of, no.
But, I really thought
that my dad didn't love me, you know,
he scarred me,
because he used to tell me,
that, he found me in a
oily blanket in the alley,
and all this, you know.
He used to say things like, you know,
just to hurt my feelings
or whatever, you know.
Call me names like Bubble Eye,
Fish Eye Foo's, and stuff
like that, you know.
And I got, like, a whooping everyday.
If I didn't do it, my
sister's blame was on me.
And by that time I figured,
well, okay, well, I did do it, you know.
Had me believin' that I did, you know?
Once I got out of grade school
and went to junior high,
that's when all my problems started.
Because I didn't feel like I was,
you know, worthy enough
to, you know, keep on
goin' with that, you know,
to fit in with those.
I didn't think I could do the work,
or whatever, 'cause, like,
well I didn't give it a chance,
I used to ditch school, you know.
Becau-, people used to tease me a lot, so,
I had very low self-esteem.
Very low.
- [Mark] And what'd you do...
How far did you go in school?
- To the twelfth grade.
- [Mark] And after school you went where?
- The streets, I was
already in the streets.
- [Mark] You were working as a prostitute?
- Yeah, I did that.
I did that, you know.
- [Mark] What age did you
start working the streets?
- My dad put me in a girls
home called Garden Gates,
and I went home,
one day I was supposed
to go on a home pass
and I never went back home.
You know, I started working the streets
and stuff like that,
to support my habit,
I had got into drugs.
Got started on crack,
and...
Wow.
Mm.
I had a lot of bad experiences, you know?
It-, it's...
- [Mark] What kinda
stuff did you go through?
- Raped, more than once, you know?
'Cause I was doing anything
for crack, at that time,
because I didn't know no better, you know.
Until I learned,
from my experiences of
living it, you know,
that, it's not all about that,
because I'm worth more
than that, you know.
But as the years went by,
I just, I started learnin'
from the lifestyle,
forced to be in the street life.
I basically raised myself.
'Cause I never went back home.
- [Mark] And you were working
with a pimp, or on your own?
- I had a pimp, in the beginning.
I ran into one,
and, he was teachin' me how to steal,
out of tricks cars,
and, you know, like,
where to search,
and, you know, like if they get out to go
and get the room, start
searching, or whatever.
How to, you know, all kinds of stuff,
you know, I went to prison twice.
By me robbin' somebody,
goin' by, you know, from the stuff
that he had taught me
what to do, you know,
I went to jail, they gave me five years.
My second term was 10.
I did nine years, nine
months, and 28 days.
- [Mark] This was for what?
- Robbery.
- [Mark] Robbery.
- Two-eleven,
with, attempt to do
bodily harm and kidnap.
- [Mark] And that was in connection
with the prostitution work?
- Yes, all in connection with that, yes.
- [Mark] So, very, very often
a prostitute is actually,
her motivation is robbery.
- That was my thing, but-,
which I've turned my life around on that.
You know, I learned, you know, okay well,
you can't do that, you know.
You know I'm gonna get caught,
You know.
just 'cause I don't get caught,
somebody might've come back on me,
I might run into the same person again.
- [Mark] Is it a common thing
that a prostitute is using sex as a way
to distract the man, so
you can actually steal?
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- [Mark] A lot of men
don't understand that.
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] They think it's sex for money,
but it's actually sex
for distraction, and-
- Clearly.
- [Mark] Robberies.
- Absolutely, Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
- [Mark] But you've had bad
experiences working the street?
- A whole lot, a whole lot.
- [Mark] What's the worst
thing that's happened?
- I've been raped
and beat up, a lot, you know.
One guy could be mad at one female,
and come back and take
it out on the next one.
You know what I'm saying?
What she didn't do, he'll make me-,
he'll make the next person do, you know,
and that's what, you know, forged the life
that I was livin' for, is the robbery
and, you know, I could piss him off today,
tomorrow, he's going to take it out
on the next female.
Somebody else that he
picks up or whatever.
You know.
You know, but all John's
would not like, you know,
I didn't have to do
that with a lot of 'em, you know.
A lot of 'em had, you know,
empathy for me, you know,
and was willing to, listen, you know,
try to comfort me to a certain extent.
(car starting in background)
I had to really go out,
I never felt like I was a,
like, a part of my family,
I was always-, you know,
I felt like an outsider,
because, if I didn't have anything
to give them, you know,
my whole family was on drugs so,
if I didn't have nothin' to give 'em,
then they really didn't
wanna be bothered with me.
You know, they was only around me
because of what I had, you know,
to give or to share, you know,
somethin' like that.
I had to go out in the streets
and have-, find trying
to looking for love,
looking for love in the wrong places.
- [Mark] And your relationship
with your pimp was,
romantic, or all business?
- Never, never.
It was all about the money.
- [Mark] And you give him all your money?
- I did, to a certain extent.
I was very young.
- [Mark] And did you ever get anything
out of it, financially?
- No, he'd take it all, you know.
Until I learned, you know,
I was 12, you know, 14, 15,
he would take all my money.
Beat me up, he would beat me up,
I would run and hide from him,
I'll be in people's houses,
saying don't tell him I'm in here
and, you know, he'd find me,
beat me up, you know,
and put me right back on the corner.
- [Mark] What age did you
start working as a prostitute?
- When, when? I was 12.
- [Mark] 12.
- Yes sir.
- [Mark] Wow.
And how does a 12-year-old end up there?
- Well, I told you,
the lady that my dad was called...
was supposed to be my dad's girlfriend,
hit my sister,
and I told her
and I hit her, you know.
He told me, you can't
chastise my women for me.
You think you grown, then
you can go on and see,
I'll show you that you're
not grown, you know.
There's a big responsibility, you know.
He made me like a...
He said,
you think you grown, then go ahead.
I never went back home, you know.
- [Mark] So you ran away.
- I did, I did.
And I never went back.
I was caught,
and I was arrested,
and, instead of them releasin' me,
he told them to put me in a girl's home
called Garden Gates.
For all girls.
(bell ringing in background)
I went there,
and when I did get out of there,
I started all over again,
right back to the same thing, you know.
It was repeated, these things, you know,
the lifestyle, you know, it's...
I wanted to get high,
that's it, you know what I mean.
I wanted to get high.
And in order for me to get high,
I know what it took for me to get high,
get my own.
So, I didn't have to ask anybody for,
you know, anything.
Which I had to do, sometimes,
I had to, you know, man up,
and do what I had to do to get it.
You know?
Not that I wanted to, it
was all about the money.
- [Mark] Do you remember
your very first time,
as a 12-year-old?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] Was that your
first time having sex,
or were you already...
- My first time, yeah, I was 12.
Mm-hmm.
This guy that used to work for my dad.
It was one of his customers,
and he used to always come to my house,
he used to say, if you
was a little bit older.
If you was just a little bit older.
And, you know, I was real fast, you know.
He told me that,
when I got out that girl's home,
I happened to run into him downtown,
down here and...
On Fifth and,
what's that, comin' from Broadway?
- [Mark] San Pedro?
- San Pedro, yeah.
And there was a Fat
Burger, the hard rock bar.
I used to meet him,
'cause this is where my mom was too.
So, you know...
But I happened to see him,
I ran into him and he was like,
when I got into his car,
He was like, can you give
me a ride to my dad's?
And I got in his car,
and he said, my place or yours,
and we went to the Snooty Fox.
And I've been doin' what I do
ever since then, you know,
it's not like, you know...
It went from bad to worse,
from worse to, you know.
Me bumpin' my head on my experiences,
or whatever, but...
That's just how life is, you know.
- [Mark] So, a 12-year-old,
that gets picked up,
or starts working as a prostitute,
with a pimp, especially, is that...
are you being tricked or
trafficked into doing that?
- [Tanya] A lot of times,
those tricks do trick the girls, you know.
Promises, you know.
- [Mark] In your case,
was that your decision,
or somebody else kinda got you into it?
- [Tanya] I didn't have
a decision, you know,
he just snatched me up, you know.
He like, gangster-ed me,
tellin' me what I'm gonna do,
you know what I'm saying?
You know, or what he gonna do to me, so...
- [Mark] And could you
get out if you wanted to?
- [Tanya] I didn't think
I could, but I did.
I ended up gettin' a gun out
of one of the trick's cars,
and I pulled it on him,
and I let him know,
if he ever hit me again,
what I was gonna do to him, you know.
And, they found him in his car.
Somebody had, gave him a hot-shot,
and he, you know, he was dead.
- [Mark] That's how you got away.
- [Tanya] Yeah.
- [Mark] Wow.
And do you have children?
- [Tanya] I have five.
- [Mark] And did you raise 'em?
- [Tanya] Yes, three of 'em.
The other two were drug babies.
Nothing that I'm proud of,
but, I am in my kids' life now.
- [Mark] How are your kids doing?
- [Tanya] Great, they're doing great.
Tremendous job.
I am proud of 'em, I can say that much.
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- [Tanya] I will be...
Thursday's my birthday, I will be 52.
- [Mark] 52.
Are you still working the streets?
- No.
No, no, no.
That life is over with, for me.
I'm a married woman.
Yeah, I've been married for 18 years.
- [Mark] Well, good for you.
- That life has been gone.
Over with.
- [Mark] What advice
would you give to a girl,
who's considering doing that for a living?
- If she can get out, get out, you know.
Don't go for anything
that anybody tell you,
'cause it's a lot of ways
of trickin' a person, you know.
Sayin' one thing,
but then it's something else, you know.
You have to be smart.
See, like I tell my kids,
stay in school,
you don't have to depend
on nobody, you know.
It's all about education,
education is power, you know.
It is.
Like my baby, she's 17, you know.
She was a straight-A student,
and, you know, she told me something,
and one day she called me
and told me that,
she wanted to talk to me, she needed me,
and I was like, I'm comin', I'm on my way,
what's wrong, what's wrong?
She said, I'm just tired of doing drugs.
I said, drugs?
Honestly, I didn't know what
to say to her, you know.
'Cause it was a shock to me,
you know, it was, like, hard, you know.
What do I say to my
daughter, I mean, like...
She told me, she said, mom,
I know about the drugs, I know what you do
and it's like, I was
like thrown back, like-
What do I say to my daughter, you know?
And she...
Children mimic their parents.
They mimic what they see, you know,
and, that's the last thing
I wanted my daughter,
you know, she's never seen me do it,
but, she knew I had a problem.
She knew.
Even as a kid, you know,
from, you know, one on up,
she knew, I told her,
I said, well, I do have an addiction,
and it's a sickness.
And she used to tell me, I got medicine.
Nana got medicine in the cabinet.
No, not that kinda medicine,
that's not what I want.
But anyway,
she told me she did drugs.
She said she did just about everything.
She said she tried it,
and they do it at her school,
and, that blew my hair back.
That threw me for a big loop.
And I told her, I said,
the next time you get that urge,
of you're angry,
you're stressed out,
or you're bored,
and, you know, you want-
just call me, just call me, you know.
Don't go, use, you know,
don't do that again,
because, I found out she was smokin' weed,
I told her that's not good,
because see, weed...
Anything alters the mind,
takes full control, basically,
is what I explained to her.
And you cannot study
in school smoking weed,
that's when it started,
from the weed, for her.
So, my daughter, you know,
she told me she would,
she'll give me a call, you know.
Other than that, you know,
I was shocked when she told
me she tried everything,
I'm like, you told me you hit the pipe?
Yes, mom.
I did the pipe, I did the crystal,
she told me she shot dope in her arms.
I said, I wanna know how,
if you did that, how did it make you feel?
I mean, what was the side effects?
How did you feel after you did it?
She said she was very sick.
For a couple days, you know.
I said, good.
Please don't do that again.
'Cause that's only effect that I observed,
towards people being on dope,
using needles, you know.
- [Mark] Do you think that teenagers,
young kids growing up in the-
- It's different, it's
different, you know.
'Cause when I was growin' up,
it wasn't like that, you know.
- [Mark] But now it seems
like it's the norm, almost.
- Exactly.
- [Mark] To do drugs,
to get into the street
life, to do all this.
- Yeah, they wanna fit
in, you know, that's all.
You know, they wanna
become someone, you know.
or be like someone.
She always told me she
wanted to be like me,
- [Mark] I'm sure there's exceptions.
- But I told her I wanted her
to be better than me, huh?
- [Mark] I'm sure there's exceptions but-.
- Absolutely.
- [Mark] It seems like there's a lot of...
- Well, you could teach any child,
you could tell them anything,
'til they get a certain age,
their mind is made up
to do what they wanna do, regardless.
It's not all about what you taught 'em.
But, when you unveil the
right teaching to 'em,
you don't have to worry about that.
But you don't know what goes on
when you're not in their presence 24/8.
You know, so...
- [Mark] What do you think
the most misunderstood
thing is about women
that work as prostitutes,
that outsiders don't understand?
- You can't teach me nun about the streets
if you ain't lived it.
You have to go out there
and live that life
in order to know about it.
Right, some people go to programs
and stuff like that, you know.
It's all certain type of addictions.
Some people do that just for a living.
Some people do that
because that's what they like,
that's their preference.
You understand what I'm sayin'?
Some people do it because
that's all they have to do, you know,
they don't have a choice.
It's all based on choices.
- [Mark] What was the
best time of your life?
- (sighs deeply) I
don't know, I can't say.
Well, when I got married, yes, yeah.
One of my best times.
- [Mark] Which was recently.
- No, 18 years ago.
- [Mark] Oh, 18 years ago.
You've been married 18 years?
- Yes sir.
- [Mark] Wow.
- My husband is disabled now but um...
(tongue clicks) We have a history.
- [Mark] What's the most important lesson
you've learned, in life?
- Hmm.
If I knew then what I know now,
there's no way I would
ever got involved in drugs.
And if I can, teach somebody else that,
you know,
explain it to 'em, or tell 'em about it.
Don't do it.
If you don't do drugs,
don't let nobody entice you,
trick you, none of that.
'Cause it's not a good thing to do.
It's not.
- [Mark] All right, Tanya.
Well thank you for sharing your story.
- Absolutely, no problem.
- [Mark] It was nice
hearing your whole life.
- Great.
- Thank you.